[Music]
the mob is very rarely turned the best
you could hope for with a mob is to calm
them down a little but there they'll
rarely turn I think sometimes you have
to walk and certainly choose your
battles you can't throw yourself against
the wall constantly and survive the way
I think about integrity is to remember
that at the end of the day there's only
one person I have to sleep with and
that's myself and am I going to be able
to at the end of the day feel that I
acted with integrity feel like I treated
other people well that I upheld
principles that I really care about and
that on some days can be really really
hard because it's not it's not the evil
people who challenge your integrity it's
the good people it's the people you like
it's the people who mostly to the time
do the right thing and what ends up
happening is because we have interests
in our lives because we're interested in
for example not unreasonably making more
money wanting a more comfortable life
wanting to take care of our friends and
family those are the kinds of things
that lead to corruption within systems
lead to misuse of resources lead to
people mistreating each other and it's
not really very hard to call out when
somebody who's known to be awful is
doing something awful it's much harder
when it's the good people around them
cooperating or being complicit in that
situation we say that for example with a
me-too movement right where people are
now exposing individuals who have been
known to be creeps and awful people but
all the people around them decided not
to stand up because it was too costly
than them personally or because they
have the attitude of it's not their job
to stand up so I think one of the things
you have to ask yourself as you think
about whether or not to call out bad
behavior is can you get other people to
do it with you that will often help
lighten the blow of
and then can you afford to lose what it
is you might lose and for some of us we
can afford that so in my own life for
example I've been able in many
circumstances to go ahead and call out
bad behavior because I have the
resources to survive the backlash but I
always try to think of at the end of the
day and at the end of my life when I
look back will I feel like I did the
right thing and that to me is really
important I I was raised in a
conservative Roman Catholic family and
so the message to my from my parents all
the time especially for my dad was
always you know if you do the right
thing you go to heaven if you do the
wrong thing you go to hell well I never
had faith it never worked for me so I
became an atheist very cognitively by
the time I was about probably 14 and
certainly by 16 and 18 I knew that I had
no belief and heaven in hell so then
there was the question how do you make
sure you do the right thing and for me
it was really clear because my mother
had said to me you know all the dogma in
the world you don't really need at the
end of the day what you need is to know
did you treat other people well did you
take care of injustice and for me that
was a very clear organizing principle so
for me I'm not thinking about what
happens after I die I'm thinking about
the end of the day and the end of my
life and thinking if I look back will I
feel good about what I did or will I
feel crummy about what I did and
Catholicism irritates me for many
reasons but one of the reasons it
irritates me is because it has the
confessional booth and what what happens
when you've done something that lacks
integrity is you go into the
confessional booth and you tell somebody
who had nothing to do with the situation
that you did it and that person forgives
you that's us I'm sorry shitty system
bleep it out if you have to that's a
system in which you you're there isn't
really accountability right where
somebody is able to just let you off the
hook and if you're going to live with
integrity you need to not have that
ability to go by the little ticket and
get-out-of-jail-free you know do your 7
Hail Mary
and be on your way you need a situation
where you have an inner voice that says
well you did that badly and you need to
make good on it and then you go and you
apologize to the person you hurt not to
the priest and you go and you promise
not to do it again not to God but to the
person you did it to and then you have I
think moral accountability on the earth
which is where we live the moral
experience we don't live it in the
afterlife every time I've ever called
out bad behavior I've been called bad
every single time when I called out the
FDA on inappropriate behavior when I
challenged the office for Human Research
protections when I named Cornell and
Mount sighs Medical School as
participating in problematic human
subjects research on pregnant women when
I at my local newspaper revealed that
City Council made deals that they
shouldn't have made that were not in the
best interests of the taxpayers over and
over and over again I've been called bad
you know there was one time in my life
that there was some kids that were
acting incredibly violently at the bus
stop and everybody turned to me and said
Alice has to fix this because Alice
fixes everything
and so because I'm the New Yorker in the
Midwest so I fix everything right and
the person who is expected to be
obnoxious and cause stuff out because
I'm a New Yorker so that's what I do
so I ended up trying to deal with this
trying to call the school system which
didn't help trying to deal with the
family which didn't help and ultimately
one day just lost it and dragged one of
these kids home and presented them to
the parents who were not at the bus stop
as they were supposed to be and the
father throttled me and in front of the
kids which was rough for me because it's
one thing to be throttled it's another
thing to scare a bunch of kids and I had
to do a lot of soul-searching about the
question of whether or not I should have
bothered right particularly because
everybody in the neighborhood kept
coming to my front door wanting to tell
me how bad they felt about this but they
wanted me to take care of them because
they were feeling bad about this and I
thought to myself well like at what
point do we say it's not my job to fix
all the bad stuff in the world but
maybe if more of us thought it was maybe
if more of us had that New Yorker voice
in our heads rather than Midwestern
voice in our heads The New Yorker voice
to me is saying do get involved the
Midwestern boy says don't get involved
don't get involved don't get involved if
more of us had the attitude of well
maybe it is our job to step up and stand
up to injustice then the pain of it
would be distributed better and we might
get things done faster the reality of
standing up in terms of integrity is
people often back away and say oh well
you have the personality or you have the
resources and you have the privilege so
you can do this but I can't do it and
the reality of whistleblowing and and
doing exposing of injustice is that
you're often alone
[Music]
you